[Music]
[Narrator:] These are Cleveland County children.
We like to think they're healthy, happy children.
[Music]
Or are these children of ours really so healthy
after all?
Can you call anyone healthy with teeth like
these in his mouth?
Bad teeth are too high a price for any child
to have to pay for civic carelessness.
Any community can save its children's teeth.
We proved that right here in Cleveland County.
[Woman 1:] But where do you start?
[Man 1:] What steps do you take?
[Woman 2:] Yes, how can we organize our town
for dental health?
[Narrator:] How?
Well these ideas have worked for us and other
towns.
Begin by encouraging your dentist to take
the lead.
They'll want to help, for they know that almost
every person suffers from some dental disease,
that more than nine out of 10 children haveone or more decayed teeth by the time they're six.
That the Army has to provide nearly a thousand fillings and extractions for every hundred men inducted.
Get your local dental association to work
with you.
It's an organization that knows the facts
on tooth decay,
one that can help you plan constructive action.
Then, rouse community-wide support.
Work with civic clubs, church groups, parent-
teacher associations, the local health department.
Reach out to every corner of your county,
the schools, the organizations,
towns and rural areas alike.
Show every member of your community how vital
it is to strike at tooth decay
and build dental health now.
Leaders of our dental health drive sent a
delegation to the state capital at Oklahoma City.
They asked Dr. Frank Bertram, Director of
Preventive Dentistry of the State Department of Health,
to help them get a sodium fluoride
demonstration team to visit Norman,
the Cleveland County seat.
These teams were set up to aid in familiarizing
both dentists and public with a new
and revolutionary technique for cutting down tooth decay: the sodium fluoride treatment.
[Music]
Dr. Bertram agreed to cooperate, and detailed plans for a countywide campaign were worked out.
Soon its scope was extended far beyond the mere promotion of the fluoride demonstration,
until it became a drive for a broad, integrated program covering the whole field of dental health.
[Music]
In developing such a campaign, it's essential
that teachers get their share of training,
background information, for the dental health
program centers in the schools.
If we're to save teeth, the biggest part of
the job must be done with children,
before bad practices take their toll.
Teachers, in turn, carry the campaign into
the classroom.
The youngsters have fun with all sorts of
projects linked to the program.
They draw pictures, write essays, make posters,
and they pick up a lot of information about
dental hygiene, too.
[Music]
Soft drinks and candy encourage tooth decay.
Children must learn to avoid them.
In one of our schools, the student health
council took up the problem.
The delegates couldn't see any reason for
keeping such tooth destroyers in the schools,
so by their own vote, they asked that all
soft drink and candy vending machines be removed.
Now the old machines are gone, replaced by
something a whole lot better.
[Music]
Some schools have even staged sodium fluoride
pageants.
They help educate parents as well as children to the fact that topical application of sodium fluoride
can cut tooth decay by 40 percent or more.
[Music]
Once mother and dad understand the importance
of topical application of sodium fluoride,
they're more than happy to cooperate.
[Music]
When the groundwork of dental health education
had been laid, the demonstration team
went to work in our schools, applying the
solution to our children's teeth,
teaching our dentists and public health workers
approved fluoridation techniques,
treating youngsters from every corner of the
county.
The topical application process itself is
quick, simple and painless.
First, each child's teeth are cleaned.
[Music]
Next, they're dried.
Then, they're painted with a 2 percent sodium
fluoride solution four times,
from two to seven days apart.
Tooth decay is cut 40 percent when four such treatments are given at proper intervals during childhood.
[Music]
But the team's job is just to demonstrate
the treatment.
It can handle only a small proportion of any
community's children during its brief stay.
That means you'll probably have to raise money
to continue the work, cash to care for all.
If you live where there's a city water system,
you'll probably want your community
to install a simple fluoride feeder such as
this one.
Such a unit injects the proper amount of fluorine
into your drinking water.
You can expect it to slice child tooth decay as much as 60 percent, and it only costs about ten cents
per person per year once the equipment is
installed.
[Music]
Oklahoma's State Board of Health has already outlined the correct procedure for your town
to follow in arranging for fluoridation.
There's nothing at all complicated about it.
Start by getting an okay from your local physicians
and dentists and health department.
Then ask your city council to enact a fluoridation
ordinance.
Once it's passed, equipment to feed fluorine
into the water system can be purchased and installed.
But fluoridation and education can't eliminate all tooth troubles.
There's still a vital need for regular dental
care.
That means more work, more money, more concentration
on this continuing four-point program to blast your target, tooth decay.
First, build a strong dental health committee.
Second, teach your town tooth care.
Third, provide fluoridation for all, topically
or in drinking water,
and fourth, make available regular professional
dental care.
This, then, is one way to organize for dental
health, one way to tackle tooth decay.
These are some of the things we and others have done, the things your community too, can do.
A hard job?
Yes, sometimes.
Uniting people behind any program takes effort,
but that's the way with almost anything worthwhile.
And what could be more worthwhile than the
fight for better health, better teeth,
less dental pain for your community's boys
and girls?
[Music]